hello welcome back i'm dom and this is
the map of black holes which isn't a map
of where all the black holes are in
space it's a concept map of the subject
of black holes laying out our current
knowledge of them the evidence for their
existence and the many outstanding
mysteries still to be solved they're
very strange and fascinating objects
i find concept maps are really useful to
give you a good overall idea of a field
of research so here's the current state
of knowledge about black holes
on earth getting into space in a space
rocket is really hard because we need to
climb out of the earth's gravity well
but in a way we're lucky if the earth
was just 50 percent larger by diameter
it would be impossible to get into orbit
with any of our current technology this
would mean no astronauts no satellites
no gps or google earth so the stronger
the gravity of a planet the higher the
escape velocity you need and black holes
are the most extreme example of this
where the escape velocity exceeds the
speed of light there is so much mass
squeezed into such a small volume that
nothing can escape because nothing can
travel faster than the speed of light
hence the name black hole which weirdly
comes from the black hole of calcutta a
notorious prison where people went in
but nobody ever left alive
although this name black hole only
caught on in the late 1960s before that
they were referred to as dark stars
frozen stars or gravitationally
collapsed objects
the original idea that black holes could
exist came from our understanding of
einstein's theory of relativity
published in 1915 where gravity is
explained as the curvature of space-time
the more dense an object is the more it
curves space-time and the more curvature
there is the stronger the force of
gravity
in 1916 carl schwarzschild found a
solution to the field equations of
relativity which predicted a special
distance from the black hole called the
schwarzschild radius but also known as
the event horizon beyond which nothing
can escape this event horizon was long
considered a mathematical curiosity
until the 60s and 70s where theoretical
developments and experimental evidence
mounted up and people realized black
holes did actually exist in our universe
here is a common visualization of the
warping of space-time around a black
hole although this is just a visual
analogy
these squiggly lines represent photons
which are actually traveling in straight
lines they only look like they curve
around because they're travelling
through a curved space time
this phenomenon is known as
gravitational lensing
the inner horizon is a feature of
rotating black holes rotating and
non-rotating black holes have got
distinct features which we'll see when
we look at their structures in a bit
at the center of a black hole is the
singularity where all of the mass of the
black hole is squeezed into an
infinitely small region of infinite
density creating an infinite curvature
of space-time
well that's probably not actually true
this is a strong indication that we're
pushing the theory into a realm where
it's not really built to cover
really we need a theory of quantum
gravity and people think that if we
could add the laws of quantum mechanics
to general relativity this could explain
what's going on in the center of a black
hole
the theory of quantum gravity is the
holy grail of theoretical physics which
is why black holes are so fascinating
because they're one of the few places in
the universe where gravity gets big
enough
to be as strong as the other
three fundamental forces and so general
relativity and quantum mechanics are
both needed to explain what's going on
inside black holes
another way to visualize the motion of
particles near a black hole is using
space-time diagrams far from a black
hole we see the squiggly lines traveling
at 45 degrees which represents lights
traveling at the speed of light
because this is the cosmic speed limit
anything with mass will have
trajectories at some angle in between
these limiting cases which is
traditionally referred to as a light
cone
as you get closer and closer to the
black hole this light cone bends towards
it due to the curvature of space-time
and if you cross the event horizon all
paths point inwards to the center
which means that whatever direction you
travel in you're always moving towards
the center of the black hole
every possible future ends up with you
getting squished
it's kind of like space and time
switch rolls because outside the event
horizon time only goes forwards but
inside the only direction you can move
is forwards in towards the singularity
and it's called an event horizon because
any event
that happens inside the black hole can
never be seen by anyone outside so it
literally is the horizon over which
events can never be seen
most black holes that we know of are
created from the remnants of dying stars
when stars exhaust their fuel they
perish in a variety of dramatic ways
depending on their mass
stars whose cores have a mass less than
1.4 times the mass of the sun collapse
into white dwarf stars
above this limit known as the chandra
shaker limit stars explode in a violent
supernova and collapse into a neutron
star
the incredible pressure of all that
matter in the core overcomes the
electrons ability to repel each other
known as the electron degeneracy
pressure and the electrons and protons
join together to make an incredibly
dense star made of pure neutrons
then above that the theory says that a
star with a core mass of above 2.17
times the mass of the sun will collapse
into an even denser object a black hole
there is a possibility that there are
other stars more dense than a neutron
star and less dense than black holes
made of some form of exotic matter
perhaps quark stars or strange stars but
these are hypothetical and we've got no
evidence of them so far
but exploding stars is only one
mechanism for black hole formation there
are giant black holes out there called
supermassive black holes with masses of
millions of times to tens of billions of
times the mass of the sun
how they got so big is still an open
question did they grow bigger over time
absorbing other matter and black holes
did they form from the universe's
earliest massive stars or perhaps they
formed directly after the big bang from
the primordial gas collapsing in on
itself we don't yet know and this is
still active research
at the small mass scale it's
theoretically possible to have very low
mass black holes the key feature of a
black hole is not so much its mass but
the very high density of that mass and
so some people have wondered if tiny
black holes might be created in particle
collisions like in the large hadron
collider at cern
you might remember at the time a media
scare that there might be black holes
created in switzerland that gobbled up
the earth
but this was total nonsense because
we got particles from space called
cosmic rays with way higher energies
than anything we can create on earth and
anything that was created at cern and
they don't create black holes in the
atmosphere
so there's absolutely no evidence that
miniature black holes are created from
particle collisions so perhaps there's a
lower mass limit to black holes that we
don't know about but this is another
open question
here's how the different masses of black
holes are typically classified according
to mass and size micro black holes would
have a mass up to the mass of the moon
but would be tiny having a radius of
their event horizons of 0.1 millimeters
or less
stellar black holes of approximately 10
times the mass of the sun are about 30
kilometers in radius
intermediate black holes are about a
thousand times the mass of the sun and
are a similar size to the earth with a
radius of about a thousand kilometers
although the earth actually has a radius
of six thousand so i kind of got this
picture wrong
supermassive black holes have masses
from a hundred thousand times the mass
of the sun to tens of billions of solar
masses and they're so big they get as
big as 400 astronomical units
for context one astronomical unit is the
distance from the earth to the sun and
so 400 astronomical units is about 10
times the orbit of pluto it's insane to
imagine a black hole that big
just want to chime in here and say if
you're enjoying this video this black
hole poster is available to buy at my
dftba store
and also i'm very excited to announce
that i've launched our professor astro
cap books
they're written by me illustrated by my
friend ben newman and if you enjoy my
videos this is basically the same kind
of thing for kids
we've got books covering all of space
all of physics all of the human body and
all of the oceans and each book comes
with a free pack of postcards with some
of my maps relevant to each book we've
been making these books for years and
we've put a lot of love and care into
them to make them as excellent as
possible so if you've got a youngster in
your life who you want to introduce to
science in a fun way check those out too
let's take a closer look at the anatomy
of black holes we've already talked
about the event horizon and the
singularity but there are many other
interesting features we need to talk
about near a black hole clocks run slow
this is the effect of the highly curved
space time which causes time dilation
this means that the experience of
someone who's falling into a black hole
would be quite different to the
experience of someone watching them fall
in
if you traveled over the event horizon
you wouldn't really notice anything but
then depending on the size of the black
hole it wouldn't be long until you got
completely spaghettified
if however you're watching someone
falling into a black hole as they
approached the event horizon they would
steadily move in slow motion as their
local clock slowed down
they'd also get more and more
red-shifted until they looked like a red
smudge on the event horizon that
gradually faded out of existence as the
wavelength of light they emit got longer
and longer
and then we have the singularity which
i've already talked about but basically
it's a region of infinite curvature
where all of the mass is squeezed into
zero volume with infinite density but
this implies a breakdown of general
relativity and really a theory of
quantum gravity is needed
so more important features of a black
hole outside at three times the schroth
shield radius is the innermost stable
circular orbit which is the minimum
distance a test particle could orbit the
black hole in a circle and this marks
the inner edge of an accretion disk of
in-falling matter around the black hole
and at one point five the schrock shield
radius is the photon sphere which is the
only possible circular orbit for a
massless particle and if you sat here
because photons are going all the way
around the black hole you can look at
the back of your own head this also
marks the closest distance any
elliptical orbit of any kind of matter
can get if anything travels below this
it'll either get slingshotted out of the
black hole's gravity or eventually
spiral in
also black holes give off hawking
radiation from the event horizon
although this is very very faint and
it's impossible for us to detect this
unless we could somehow get very very
close to a black hole
it's worth noting here that black holes
don't have any special suction powers
where they go around the galaxy
hoovering everything up the the gravity
of a black hole is the same shape as any
other massive body so at a distance
being around a black hole would feel
just like being around any other star
with the same mass gravitationally
speaking
they're special because they're so dense
so when you get close into them you
experience a way higher gravity than you
could ever get anywhere else
this picture so far only applies to
non-rotating black holes the picture for
a rotating black hole is a little more
complicated as shown here now you may
wonder if you ever get
non-rotating black holes as
everything in the universe that we see
is spinning in some way but
theoretically you can get non-rotating
black holes because hawking radiation
takes away some of the angular momentum
from the black hole which would
gradually slow down their spin but it
would take a very very long time for
this to happen
non-rotating black holes are spherical
but rotating black holes are a squashed
oval shape
also the singularity in the center is no
longer a point but a singularity ring
and they have a region outside the event
horizon called the ergosphere which is a
region where it be impossible to stand
still because the rotation of the black
hole drags space-time around it in a
process called frame dragging which is
kind of like a whirlpool of space-time
and the frame dragging is so fast inside
the ergosphere that you'd have to travel
faster than the speed of light just to
stand still
so you can move around in the ergosphere
but only in the direction of the
rotation of the black hole
at the edge of the ergosphere is the
innermost stable orbit the minimum
distance to the black hole a particle
can maintain a stable orbit
many real black holes are surrounded by
an accretion disk a cloud of material
that's falling into the black hole and
generating lots of heat and energy as
the particles speed up and crash into
each other
accretion disks are very bright sources
of x-ray radiation and high energy
particles which can fly out to the
ergosphere with way more energy than
they entered stealing angular momentum
from the black hole as they do so and
using it as a slingshot
finally the incredible gravity around a
black hole leads to some interesting
gravitational lensing effects on the
accretion disk resulting in this
familiar image
in reality the accretion disk is
actually a pancake shape but we can see
the accretion disk that would normally
be hidden behind the black hole because
the light from it which travels upwards
or downwards is bent around the black
hole and comes towards us so it looks
like there's an accretion disk above and
below the black hole but we're actually
seeing the top and bottom of the
accretion disk that's behind the black
hole
i've been talking for a long time about
the theory but how do we know that black
holes actually exist well over the last
50 years we've built up a large body of
observational evidence from many
different techniques
the first was from x-ray astronomy as
the radiation from the accretion disk is
mostly x-ray radiation
the process that produces this x-ray
radiation in the accretion disk is one
of the most efficient energy producing
processes known where the spiraling
material gets up to 40 percent of its
rest mass converted into energy to
understand how hugely remarkable this is
we can compare this to the nuclear
fusion process that powers the sun and
all the stars here only 0.7 of the rest
mass is converted into energy way less
than 40 percent
so the accretion disk is nearly 60 times
more violent than a burning star
the very first black hole that was
discovered was discovered this way in
1971 and is called cygnus x1 since then
we've discovered around 100 more
although this is just a tiny sample of
the number of black holes that are
thought to exist in our galaxy and every
single galaxy is thought to have a
supermassive black hole in its center
often accretion disks are accompanied by
relativistic jets which emit even higher
energy particles and radiation than from
the accretion disk the mechanism that
creates these jets is not currently
known
we see many high energy sources in space
and we think many of them are caused by
the accretion of matter into black holes
these include active galactic nuclei and
quasars which are thought to be the
accretion disks of supermassive black
holes and also ultraluminous x-ray
sources thought to be from intermediate
mass black holes
also things called x-ray binaries are
most likely to consist of a normal star
and a black hole orbiting each other
while the black hole gradually sucks
away mata from the star and short-lived
streamers are thought to be stars which
shine incredibly brightly as they're
being swallowed up by a black hole
before disappearing
an entirely different line of evidence
comes from the center of our own galaxy
by tracking the orbits of about a
hundred stars which have been observed
to be orbiting around an invisible
massive object called sagittarius a star
by tracing the orbits and measuring the
velocities of the orbiting stars
astrophysicists have been able to
calculate the mass of the central body
to be a humongous 4.3 million times the
mass of the sun
but this mass is confined to a region of
less than
0.002 light years signs that it must be
a supermassive black hole
even more recently in 2019 the first
direct image of the accretion disk
around a black hole was constructed from
the radio waves emitted by the galactic
center of the messier 87 galaxy and it
had the features of an accretion disk
that we expected if a little blurry
but constructing this image was a feat
of radio astronomy and was achieved by
combining the signals from eight radio
telescopes all around the world to
create a virtual telescope the size of
the earth an amazing achievement
just as incredible was the detection of
gravitational waves by ligo in 2016
which uses finely tuned lasers in a
giant l shape to detect the minuscule
changes of distance caused by the
rippling of space-time when
gravitational waves pass through the
earth
the first gravitational waves they
detected were created by a pair of
stellar mass black holes spiraling into
each other and finally merging into a
larger black hole and converting around
five percent of their mass into
gravitational waves
and since then ligo and virgo have
detected many more collisions
finally there's a proposed method called
microlensing which has been seen many
times for stars but not as far as we
know for black holes
i've talked about how the strong
gravitational field around a black hole
causes a lensing effect the idea is we
could use this to detect black holes
when they pass in front of a star
we've seen things like supernovae be
gravitationally lensed by massive
objects like entire galaxies but if we
found a binary system where a star is
orbiting a black hole we could
potentially see the radiation from the
star being bent towards us as it passes
behind the black hole which would give
us information about the black hole it's
orbiting and would be a really cool
technique for the future of black hole
observations
now let's take a quick look at the
theoretical understanding of black holes
which started in 1916 but was really
fleshed out in the 60s and 70s when
black holes were taken seriously as real
physical objects not just mathematical
curiosities here is the equation for the
radius of a non-rotating black hole
which gives a simple relationship with
its mass where g is the gravitational
constant and c is the speed of light but
this gets more complicated if the black
hole has spin or charge
the general description of black holes
developed in the 60s is called the no
hair theorem and states that a
stationary black hole can be completely
described by just three parameters mass
angular momentum and electric charge
then in the 70s a theory of black hole
thermodynamics was developed which
describes the links between black hole
mass and energy how the surface area of
a black hole relates to its entropy and
how the surface gravity relates to
temperature
then stephen hawking applied quantum
field theory to black holes and showed
that black holes radiate hawking
radiation energy from the event horizon
with a characteristic black body
spectrum where the temperature is
proportional to the surface gravity of
the black hole
so black holes will gradually lose their
mass over time by radiating away hawking
radiation
but this evaporation is slowest for the
largest black holes and fastest for the
smallest black holes which means that
micro black holes would be very
short-lived but supermassive black holes
will live for
over 10 to 100 years which is
a ludicrous amount of time and those
will be the last objects that will exist
before the heat death of the universe
what is going on
oh it's just a car this all gives you a
good idea about what we think we
understand about black holes but there
are many outstanding mysteries which we
know about and these all seem to boil
down to our lack of a theory of quantum
gravity i've already mentioned how
singularities probably don't exist
because you can't have a thing that's
infinitely small with infinite density
so there's a question what actually
happens to matter at the singularity
unfortunately if we ever found out
experimentally because of the event
horizon we couldn't ever get the results
out to anyone which is
a bit of an issue to ever
figure out
what's going on in the singularity
also in the description of spinning or
charged black holes there's a
hypothetical possibility of them
containing an unstable wormhole which
would let you leave the black hole but
in a completely different space time
they also have regions inside them where
it would be possible to travel to your
own past along closed time-like curves
which creates one of those time-travel
grandfather paradoxes
but although these ideas are tantalizing
from a science fiction perspective both
of these will probably go away with a
proper quantum description of black
holes
there are other theoretical objects
which have been conjectured but there's
no evidence for them yet these include
stars somewhere in between neutron stars
and black holes but these are all highly
speculative
also white holes which are like black
holes but where the event horizon goes
the other way information can come out
but nothing can ever go in
[Music]
and finally naked singularities which
are singularities which could be
observed because they don't have an
event horizon but these are thought to
be unphysical and so not actually
possible
but these aren't as interesting as the
real theoretical puzzles
first of all is the holographic
principle which is complicated to
explain but the general gist of it is
that black holes might be telling us the
whole universe is actually a hologram
this is a strange result of the entropy
of a black hole in every other thing in
the universe entropy scales with the
volume of that thing but in black holes
it scales with the surface area
and this implies that anything that
happens within a volume of space-time
can be described by data on the surface
of that volume
so we're all a hologram
but again we'd need a theory of quantum
gravity to properly calculate the
entropy of a black hole so this is still
active work
finally we have one of the biggest
unsolved mysteries of black holes what
happens to the information that falls
into them
now because black holes are only defined
by three parameters mass charge and
angular momentum any other information
about objects that fall into the black
hole
appears to be erased from the universe
but the thing is this isn't actually
allowed by a fundamental law of quantum
mechanics called unitarity
so for example an electron has got a
load of quantum numbers associated with
it that define it like lepton number but
if an electron falls into a black hole
this information is lost because the
black hole only preserves mass charge
and angular momentum
so one attempt to explain this is a
theory called complementarity which says
that the information does actually come
back out again but in the hawking
radiation trouble was this was shown to
fail by a further paradox called the
firewall paradox now the details of all
of these things are quite complicated
but the end result is that to resolve
all of these paradoxes about information
we may need to give up one of the
fundamental rules in the laws of physics
either einstein's equivalence principle
unitarity in quantum mechanics or
local quantum field theory
overall i hope i've conveyed why black
holes are such fascinating objects to
study as they're the most extreme
environments in the universe where
gravity and quantum physics meet and
their very existence seems to break our
fundamental theories of physics
but by studying them
the hope is we may actually uncover some
subtle clues that could help guide us to
the next level of understanding so
perhaps
black holes are actually the
experimental key to developing a theory
of quantum gravity or
perhaps we'll just be as confused as we
are now forever
this section of the video is sponsored
by brilliant a longtime supporter of
this channel and because of that you may
already know that it's a website an app
based on the idea that active problem
solving rather than just watching videos
is the best way to properly learn a
subject by actually sitting down and
solving problems and i agree brilliant
have recently increased the
interactivity on their platform to a new
level with new tools so that you can get
in and get a feel for what you're
learning like this lesson on the center
of mass where you can shift around the
balance points to see how these weights
balance or don't and if you want to
learn more about gravity they've got a
whole course on gravitational physics
where you can gain a mastery of concepts
like escape velocity orbits or
gravitational fields if you're
interested go to my special link
brilliant.org dos you can click on the
first link in the description below and
this helps me out because they know
you've come from here and on top of that
the first 200 people to sign up via the
link will get a 20 discount on the
premium subscription which unlocks all
of their content a big thanks to
brilliant for all of their support on
this channel and a big thanks to you for
watching i hope you've enjoyed this
video and i'll see you on the next one
you